for every mega expensive blockbuster
grossing more than a billion dollars
worldwide as always a mega expensive
box-office flop greeted by moviegoers
with all the enthusiasm of tax day now
every major studio film seems to cost
upwards of a hundred million dollars to
produce and inevitably many movies never
come close to making that money back
these are the films whose production
bills and astronomical marketing budgets
landed them on the list of the biggest
flops of the past 15 years Speed Racer
2008 Speed Racer was a risky proposition
to begin with an adaptation of a manga
and anime from the late 60s with
little-known Emile Hirsch in the lead
Studio Village Roadshow and distributor
Warner Brothers however had no qualms
about throwing money at the vehicle
along with a reported 120 million dollar
price tag Speed Racer
additionally had one of the most
expensive advertising campaigns and
media blitzes ever for a film the gambit
failed spectacularly a Speed Racer was
among the first in a long line of
casualties who dared to duel Marvel
Studios Go Go Go Speed Racer didn't with
a mere 18 million dollars opening
weekend making matters worse it was
demolished by Ironman in its second week
of release The Chronicles of Narnia
Prince Caspian opening the following
weekend that didn't help matters either
and Speed Racer stored out to a 94
million dollar worldwide gross the flop
ultimately lost Village Roadshow and
Warner Brothers a cool 100 million
dollars Sahara it's the kind of pokey
fun that should have made for an
entertaining flick Sahara was an attempt
to kick-start a new adventure franchise
in the mould of Indiana Jones but
trouble started brewing long before the
film hit theaters in 2005 the film's
initial budget of 80 million dollars
swelled to 130 million dollars and
author Clive Cussler
who hadn't been given the final say over
the script had been promised to act on
millions in legal fees suing their
producers during an unsuccessful bid to
block the film's release finally I said
this is going down the tube yeah this
scripture getting worse and worse and
worse and finally I just kind of pulled
myself away even the fr affable Matthew
McConaughey wasn't enough to attract
audiences adding insult to injury
the legal snafu and associated fees
wormed its way through various courts
for eight more years until ultimately
being thrown out in 23rd
with a worldwide gross of only 119
million dollars Sahara was no oasis
amassing a lasts just north of 100
million dollars how do you know there's
no denying television and film
Renaissance man James L Brooks as comedy
royalty for TV he helped create the Mary
Tyler Moore Show and taxi and on the big
screen he delivered thoughtful comedies
like broadcast news but if you're
unfamiliar with his 2010 effort how do
you know you're not alone despite a cast
featuring Paul Rudd Reese Witherspoon
Owen Wilson and even Jack Nicholson the
romantic comedy barely sparked
collecting just under 49 million dollars
worldwide the most rom-coms vitaly isn't
terrible but how do you know cost an
insane 120 million dollars to produce -
in part to the whopping salaries
commanded by its stars Brooks also told
the unusual step of reshooting the
beginning and end of the film pushing
the budget into the stratosphere
audiences found the romantic comedy
neither romantic nor funny as the movie
ultimately lost 105 million dollars for
Sony that's fantastic yep it's good one
that's great Ben Hur the 1959 epic Ben
Hur is an assailable legend and at its
time was the most expensive film ever
made
creating an update to the Charlton
Heston epic after 57 years however
proved to be a major miscalculation for
co-financing Studios paramount and MGM
the production delivered plenty of CGI
spectacle but it was hampered by
absolutely toxic reviews the remake was
taken out in its opening weekend by
Suicide Squad and the debut smash hit
don't breathe the following week see
what it's tragic fate been hers eventual
94 million dollar gross wasn't even
enough to cover its 100 million dollar
budget and the movie eventually took an
estimated 120 million dollar loss the
Alamo based on the historic San Antonio
siege Disney had big plans for the Alamo
the studio lined up Ron Howard as
director it's up to red-hot Russell
Crowe to star and strategically set a
2003 holiday season release date exactly
none of those things worked out then
Disney Chief Michael Eisner walked at
the 125 million dollar budget and
slashed costs by hiring the much more
affordable john lee hancock to direct
and
ditched crow in favor of Billy Bob
Thornton unfortunately eisenerz caution
was no match for the public and critical
indifference toward the film with one
critic calling it the equivalent of one
long drone from a stiff social studies
teacher who can scarcely be bothered to
add any sort of relevance to the topic
who remembers the Alamo apparently
moviegoers didn't as a movie only grows
to poultry 25 million dollars worldwide
analysts speculate disney flushed one
hundred and twenty million dollars down
the drain on the picture making it one
of the biggest bombs ever at the time
Sindbad legend of the seven seas
dreamworks animation once look like a
champion of hand-drawn animation in an
era when it had been all but completely
phased out the Prince of Egypt was a
hand-drawn hit and the road to El Dorado
looked to keep the streak going but
their success came to abrupt end of 2003
simbad legend of the seven seas with a
modest sixty million dollar budget and a
heavyweight voice cast DreamWorks felt
confident pouring meticulous amounts of
money into a massive worldwide marketing
campaign and promotional tie-ins the
film opened against stiff competition
with the likes of Terminator 3 and
Legally Blonde to Sinbad fell overboard
earning only 18 million dollars
worldwide because of its huge marketing
budget the movie washed out with a one
hundred and twenty five million dollar
loss and DreamWorks cut ties with
old-school animation Mars Needs Moms
Mars need moms had joined gamble written
all over it
despite being produced by the legendary
Bob Zemeckis the story of a young boy
who must rescue his mother for Martians
failed to strike a chord with audiences
negative reviews cite to the animation
which many moviegoers found flattened
mechanical with a whopping 150 million
dollar budget the film would have had to
over perform just to turn a profit but
Disney executives found they needed
antacid instead of moms after the film
poured in just 39 million dollars
worldwide putting a serious dent in the
house of mouse's 2011 earnings Mars
Needs Moms never left the launch pad and
finished 130 million dollars in the hole
Tomorrowland in 2015 Disney returned to
the world of massive flops of
Tomorrowland a film with a pedigree so
solid the studio could be forgiven for
his misplaced confidence co-written and
directed by The Incredibles Oscar winner
Brad Bird and featuring a casting
George Clooney and Hugh Laurie
Tomorrowland promised an exciting brain
bending ride through alternate
dimensions and somehow managed to fall
disappointingly short this part big
little weird the film had the dubious
honour of opening at number one during
the worst Memorial Day weekend for
Hollywood in recent memory critics
panned the film for being maudlin
preachy and not adventurous enough to
live up to its premise Tomorrowland made
209 million dollars worldwide but that
barely covered its 190 million dollar
budget and analysts estimate Disney saw
one hundred and forty million dollars
vaporize on the movie The Lone Ranger in
any discussion of the most ill-conceived
would-be blockbusters of all time 2013
the Lone Ranger deserves a prominent
place the film's struggle began years
before release has produced a search for
ways to wrangle the budget down from a
proposed two hundred and sixty million
dollars when cameras finally rolled the
budget quickly spiraled out of control
again to the point where production was
briefly shut down over cost concerns the
film's release date was also delayed
several times and in the meantime images
of star Johnny Depp in full regalia as a
ranger sidekick Tonto were deemed both
ridiculous and insulting with army
hammer in the title role the film opened
to wildly in different audiences and
brutal mockery from critics the men you
seek think you are dead Kemosabe
all in all Disney and The Lone Ranger
got bucked off to the tune of a 190
million dollar loss John Carter
there are sickeningly pricey flops and
then this John Carter the movie was a
decade's long effort to adapt author
Edgar Rice Burroughs Barsoom novels into
an epic live-action Disney film when
John Carter finally made it to screens
in 2012 the sci-fi action flick just
wasn't worth the wait just how bad was
it go
shock me star Taylor catch a letter
production that found a way to be
stupendously dull despite the fact the
movie balloons up to a 250 million
dollar budget audiences were confused
critics were bored and the film's
massive marketing push left it deeper in
the red than almost any film to date
it's worldwide take of 284 million
dollars didn't come close to covering
costs and for the second year in a row
Disney was responsible for one of the
biggest flops of all time a breathtaking
200 million dollar loss Disney's dreams
of a John Carter franchise let them be
crushed like unhatched thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love today
[Music]